Доброго дня, я вчитель
хімії Світлана Новікова.
Сьогодні ми з вами починаємо
вивчати оксигеновмісні органічні сполуки.
І перший представник цього класу сполук,
цієї групи сполук - це спирти.
Спочатку розберемо,
які оксигеновмісні органічні сполуки
ми будемо вивчати в 9 класі.
Це спирти,
карбонові кислоти,
жири і вуглеводи.
В 10-му класі ви будете більше вчити
оксигеновмісних органічних
кислот, а в 9-му саме ці.
Що особливого в оксигеновмісних
органічних кислотах
у порівнянні з тим що ви
вже вчили з органічної хімії?
Це те що кожен клас оксигеновмісних
сполук містить якусь функціональну,
або її ще називають характеристичну групу.
Саме за наявністю такої групи,
можно відрізнити один
клас сполук від іншого.
Наведемо приклади кожного
класу оксигеновмісних сполук,
які ми вивчаємо в 9-му класі.
Це спирти.
Що таке спирт?
Спирт обов’язково
містить гідроксогрупу ОН
наявність такої групи
говорить про те, що це спирт
і оця гідроксогрупа пов’язана
з вуглеводневим замісником.
Гідроксогрупа може бути
одна, може бути дві і більше.
Але, наявність цієї групии
говорить, що це спирт.
Далі, карбовані кислоти.
Карбовані кислоти містять
таку характеристичну
або функціональну групу
яка називається карбоксильна,
СООН
і ця група пов’язана з
вуглеводневим замісником.
Про жири поговоримо на окремому уроці.
І, четвертий клас - вуглеводи.
Чому вони отримали таку назву?
Тому що в цих сполуках на певну кількість
атомів карбону припадає певна кількість
молекул води.
Вуглець, карбон і вода,
тому назва така, вуглеводи.
Дивлячись на оці загальні
схеми виокремимо групи,
функціональні або характеристичні.
Спирти містять ОН групу,
карбонові кислоти карбоксильну групу.
Якщо уважно придивитися до формули жирів,
то там також можно виокремити
отакі групи функціональні,
які відрізняють ці
сполуки від інших сполук.
Ми сьогодні починаємо вивчати спирти.
Знайомитися з оксигеновмісними сполуками
саме зі спиртів.
Які бувають спирти?
Вони можуть бути
одноатомні і багатоатомні.
Одноатомні спирти містять
одну гідроксильну групу
Розберемо номенклатуру.
Номенклатура це правила,
яких ми дотримуємось
коли даємо назву речовині.
Отже, одноатомні одна група ОН.
Перший представник спиртів
містить один атом карбону.
Він входить до складу
вуглеводневого замісника СН3,
це похідна від метану.
Ви вивчали вуглеводні, перші
десять мали вивчити напам'ять
Перший представник вуглеводнів це метан,
формула СН4.
Якщо в метані замість одного гідрогену
поставити групу ОН, то це вже буде спирт.
Як даємо назву?
До назви насиченого вуглеводню, в якому
стільки ж атомів карбона тобто від метану,
це метан, додаємо –ол, метанол,
або метиловий спирт.
Метиловий, тому що оцей замісник
називається метил, тому спирт метиловий.
Наступний представник
класу одноатомних спиртів
це етанол.
Чому назва етанол?
Тому що ця речовина походить від етану.
Формула на екрані
Якщо в молекулі етану
замість одного гідрогену
поставити гідроксогрупу буде С2Н5-ОН
і назва етанол,
етан і додали -ол, етанол.
Або ще називається етиловий спирт,
тому що замісник називається етил.
Багатоатомні містять
дві і більше гідроксогрупи.
Наприклад, якщо дві
гідроксогрупи, тоді має бути
щонайменше два атоми карбона,
від етану було С2Н6,
структурну формулу
можно було намалювати СН3 зв'язок СН3
і біля кожного карбону
замість одного гідрогену
поставити гідроксогрупу,
утворюється ось така сполука СН2
зв'язок ОН і СН2 зв'язок ОН.
Гідроксогрупи знаходяться
біля різних атомів карбона,
тому назва цієї речовини етан-1,2-діол,
або ще цю речовину
називають етиленгліколь.
Сьогодні ми будемо
вивчвти властивості, як фізичні,
так і хімічні багатоатомного
спирту гліцеролу.
Гліцерол або гліцерин це одне те саме.
Гліцерол це трьохатомний спирт, тобто
він містить три гідроксильні групи.
Радикал, у нас три атоми карбону
біля кожного є гідроксогрупа,
тому для того щоб дати
назву цій речовині, ми маємо
пронумерувати атоми
карбона, тут немає значення
з я кого боку 1,2,3.
Біля першого, другого і
третього є гідроксогрупа
і ми це зазначаємо.
Всього карбонів три тому починаємо пропан,
потім 1,2,3 тобто
вказуємо карбони, біля яких
знаходиться гідроксогрупа, 1,2,3 триол,
або ця речовина ще
називається гліцерин або гліцерол.
Сьогодні будемо говорити про
властивості одноатомних
одноатомних спиртів на прикладі етанолу
і багатоатомних спиртів
на прикладі гліцеролу.
Фізичні властивості:
перші представники ряду спиртів - етанол і
метанол, це рідини, хоча вони
мають не велику відносно
молекулярну масу і теоретично
мали б бути газом, але це рідини.
Спробуємо з’ясувати чому.
Для цього треба пригадати
уроки 8 класу хімічний зв’язок.
Є так званий водневий
зв’язок і водневий зв’язок
пояснює те, що вода за
звичайних умов це рідина
через те, що зв’язок між оксигеном
і гідрогеном є полярним.
Так ось гідроксогрупа
яка міститься в спиртах,
в молекулах спиртів вона є полярною
Із цих двох
елементів - оксиген і гідроген -
більш полярним є оксиген,
він тягне густину зв’язку
на себе і на ньому виникає
частково негативний заряд.
Відповідно на атомі
гідрогену виникає частково
позитивний заряд, молекула полярна.
А тепер спробуємо розібратися,
що відбувається між двома
такими полярними молекулами.
Між такими молекулами виникає зв’язок,
водневий зв’язок.
Гідроксогрупа однієї молекули
і гідроксогрупа іншої
іншої молекули, так от
зв’язок виникає між оксигеном
гідроксогрупи однієї молекули
і гідрогеном гідроксогрупи
іншої молекули - водневий зв’язок.
Завдяки водневому зв’язку
молекули наближаються,
відстань між ними
зменшується і цим пояснюється
агрегатний стан спиртів.
Агрегатний стан зумовлений
відстанню між частинками
з якої складається речовина,
у газів це велика
відстань, у рідини меньша,
у твердих ще меньша.
Оцю функцію зменшення
відстані між молекулами виконує
саме водневий зв’язок.
Завдяки водневому зв’язку який
виникає між молекулами спирти це рідини,
вже перші представники спиртів це рідина.
Етанол, формула С2Н5ОН.
Етанол це безбарвна рідина
з характерним запахом.
За запахом можна відрізнити
цю речовину від іншої.
Густина цієї рідини майже 0,.8 г/см3 -
меньша, ніж у води,
температура кипіння 78,3 град. С, тобто
меньша, ніж температура кипіння води.
Етиловий спирт дуже
добре розчиняється у воді,
змішується з водою у
будь якому співвідношенні.
Є медичний спирт 96%.
Отримати шляхом перегонки,
дистиляції стовідсотковий
спирт неможливо.
Найбільше що можна
отримати це 96%. Що це означає?
Якщо ви пригадаєте, що таке
масова частка речовини
в розчині, то можно сказати що
в 100 грамах медичного
спирту це 96г етанолу, і 4г води.
В аптеках також є 70%.
Ще раз наголошуємо що
спирт етанол змішується з водою
у будь якому співвідношенні.
Гліцерол це безбарвна,
в’язка рідина гігроскопічна
Гліцерол може поглинати воду.
Гліцерол на відміну від спирту
немає запаху,
має солодкий смак.
Давайте порівняємо
густину гліцеролу і спирту
у гліцерола 1,26 г/см3,
у спирта - 0,79 г/см3
Густина більша, це пов'язано з тим,
що у гліцеролу 3 гідроксильних групи.
Також вища температура
кипіння - 290 градусів.
Гліцерол добре розчиняється в
воді так само,
як етиловий спирт. Давайте
спробуємо розчинити
гліцерол у воді.
якщо добре помішати скляною палочкою
можна побачити, що гліцерол
добре розчиняється у воді.
Густина гліцеролу більша,
тому, коли ми додавали до води,
він був знизу, тепер ми перемішуємо і
утворюється однорідна суміш, тобто розчин.
Розчин це однорідна суміш.
Гліцерол розчиняється у воді.
Нам це сьогодні буде потрібно для досліду,
поки що відставим це.
Далі, хімічні властивості,
реакція горіння.
Якщо проаналізувати
склад етанолу і гліцеролу,
ми можемо легко побачити, що
якісний склад у цих речовин однаковий.
Вони містять карбон, гідроген і оксиген.
Пригадаемо як окиснюється, а горіння, це
повне окиснення, складні речовини.
Під час горіння тобто
повного окиснення складних
речовин утворюється
оксид кожного елемента,
який входить до складу речовини.
Розбираємо теоретично,
етанол С2Н5ОН, горіння,
це додали кисень і утворюється
вуглекислий газ і вода.
До складу етанолу
входять карбон гідроген і
утворюються відповідні оксиди
під час повного окиснення.
Спробуємо провести таку реакцію,
подивимося як горить спирт.
Додаєму невелику кількість
спирту у фарфорову чашку,
підпалюємо,
дуже добре горить.
У наслідок горіння утворюється
вуглекислий газ і вода.
Далі гліцерол, він має такий самий
якісний склад як і етанол,
тобто він складається із карбону,
гідрогену і оксигену.
І під час повного окиснення тобто горіння
утворюється вуглекислий газ і вода.
На дошці рівняння реакції.
Отже підчас горіння і етанолу
і гліцеролу утворюються
вуглекислий газ і вода,
два продукти горіння.
Наступна реакція,
якісна реакція на гліцерол.
Якісною реакцію на
гліцерол є свіже добутий
Cu(OH)2, давайте спробуємо
провести таку реакцію.
Для цого спочатку треба добути Сu(OH)2,
нас є луг NaOH,
додаємо декілька крапель CuSO4,
утворюєтся драглистий
осад блакитного кольору.
Осад це Cu(OH)2.
Тепер до цього осаду
додамо розчин гліцеролу
який ми добули раніше,
відбувається хімічна
реакція, зникає блакитний осад
і розчин стає синій.
Це якісна реакція на гліцерин,
реакція дуже складна
тому ми просто записуємо
Гліцерин плюс Cu(OH)2 і утворюється
синій розчин.
Зверніть увагу на те,
що гліцерол це багатоатомний спирт
і ось ця реакція,
це якісна реакція саме
на багатоатомний спирт.
Ми будемо вивчати інші речовини,
які містяь декілька
гідроксогруп так само як гліцерол,
так от вони будуть давати
таку самe реакцію з Cu(OH)2,
розчин буде синього
кольору, якісна реакція не
просто на гліцерол, а
на багатоатомний спирт.
Добування, як можно добути етанол.
Етанол можна добути
реакцією взаємодії етену і води.
Нагадуємо, етен формула C2H4 структурна
формула CH2 подвійний зв’язок CH2,
ця речовина належить до ряду алкенів,
це ненасичені вуглеводні,
які містять
один подвійний зв’язок плюс вода.
Якщо уявити воду як H2O,
реакція відбувається
за певної температури,
під тиском і за наявності каталізатора.
Руйнується подвійний зв’язок в молекулі
етену і гідроген приєднується
до одного карбону,
а гідроксогрупа до другого
карбону і утворюється
сполука C2H5OH.
Це реакція приєднання,
коли приєднується
вода, реакція називається
реакція гідротаціі.
Окрім цього етанол
можна добути біохімічним способом
із глюкози. В цій великій
темі оксигеновмісних
сполук ми окремо будемо вивчати глюкозу.
Глюкоза може піддаватися
спиртовому бродінню,
і при цьому утворюється
спирт і виділяється
вуглекислий газ.
Глюкоза, спиртове бродіння,
утворюється етанол і виділяється
вуглекислий газ.
Для добування гліцеролу
використовують жири. Жири змішують
з лугом за певних умов
і у наслідок цієї реакції
утворюється гліцерол і мило.
Про мило ми ще будемо
говорити і жири вивчати.
Реакція складна тому для
9го класу достатньо знати
про те, що гліцерол можно добути із жиру.
Жир з лугом утворює гліцерол і мило.
Застосування, етанол знаходить
своє застосування
частіше за все, як розчинник.
Він використовується в медицині, фармації,
готують екстракти лікарських рослин.
Етанол це сировина для
виробництва лікеро-горілчаних напоїв.
У деяких країнах, а саме
в Бразилії, використовують
суміш бензину і спирту як пальне.
Таке пальне менш шкідливе для довкілля.
І бензину тоді
треба менше і треба менше
переробляти нафти якщо додавати спирт.
Спирт можна добувати із деревини.
Гліцерол входить до
складу мила, зубних паст,
косметичних засобів, лікарських препаратів
його додають у деякий харчовий продукт
для надання їм солодкого смаку.
І окрім цього гліцерол використовують
у виробництві вибухових речовин.
Із гліцеролу виготовляють нітрогліцерин
і вже з нього виготовляють
динаміт і порох.
Як діє етанол на організм людини.
Етанол викликає сп’яніння,
під час сп’яніння
порушується мовлення, координація рухів,
може бути втрата пам’яті.
Людина не може
контролювати свої дії, вчинки.
Регулярне вживання алкоголю викликає
захворювання, яке називається алкоголізм.
І наслідком цього
захворювання є підвищений тиск,
ураження нервової,
серцево судинної систем,
печінки та підшлункової залози.
Не дивлячись на те що ми сьогодні говорили
про етанол і гліцерол,
ще декілька слів про
отруйну дію метанолу на організм людини.
Метанол має такий запах, як етанол,
його дуже легко сплутати з етанолом.
Але на відміну від етанолу,
метанолом можна одразу отруїтися.
Метанол це сильна отрута,
яка потрапляючи в організм,
окислюється до формальдегіду
і мурашиної кислоти.
Якщо людина отруїлася, вона може
втратити зір, причому зір
повернути вже не можна
або може наступити смерть. Смертельна доза
метанолу на організм людини це приблизно
від 0,5-1мл/кг маси тіла людини.
Метанол входить до складу
технічного спирту,
його використовують в
технічних цілях,
вживати метанол не можна - це отрута.
Якщо у вас є час, ви можете
подивитися ролики в інтернеті і
зробити висновки.
На цьому наш урок закінчено,
дякую за увагу, до зустрічі.